okay last night we saw this thing on
shutter about the omen it was telling
bada Jenny yes
remember we were talking about before it
was the show that's on shudder they're
putting up like one every week I think
it's like five or six episodes gonna be
and it's called cursed films and they're
gonna be talking about like last week
they did the Exorcist and then this week
they did the omen this is actually a
pretty good show the it's kind of like
they're only half an hour long I do kind
of wish one thing that I wish that they
would do is focus more on the [ __ ] that
happened you know movie and the movie or
on the movie set where it's kind of like
I mean it's interesting but you know for
example the one they did about the omen
like they talked about all the weird
[ __ ] that happened like some of the crew
members like you know relatives died and
plane crash plane crashes and [ __ ] like
that there's like a bunch of creepy [ __ ]
around the making of that movie but then
they kind of have to go off on all these
other directions like you know people
that actually believe that a satanic
cults like cursed the movie because they
didn't want it getting out and they got
a good out of the club and find your
local Satanist and ask him about it they
gotta go down to the [ __ ] local House
of Blues and find some [ __ ] dude that
can cast spells and [ __ ] and then he's
going to do his it's it's it's bad it
kind of took me back to the to the
Geraldo era satanic panic yeah yeah but
and like it took me back to kind of like
you know some of the [ __ ] they put on
television where they have to explain to
you what you do is that and then they
have to explain what magic is
sympathetic magic but you know I guess
there's a lot of kids out there that
don't really know what magic is maybe
because we were sitting there like
watching that and I was like man I
thought everybody knew what this stuff
was maybe I'm just taking it for granted
man what a voodoo doll does yeah it's
like an oh [ __ ] I thought like I like
the Saint it's kind of like [ __ ] in
search of Magnus Emmys did a kind of a
better job of talking about that kind of
stuff
yeah it's kind of creepy but you when
you hear modern people talk about that
stuff it just sounds stupid stupid yeah
because you would think that by this
stage everyone would be like kind
you popped on that [ __ ] yeah you know
what I mean or at least like know what
it is because back in the old days you
know like before we had the internet and
[ __ ] like that when you actually had to
go to the [ __ ] library or Leonard
Nimoy telling you about it on TV it's
like I can see people being ignorant
about [ __ ] then right but now I'd really
don't think there's any need for that
there's like for explaining very simple
concepts like sympathetic magic I'm
pretty sure and like even even little
kids that don't know anything about like
[ __ ] anthropology really they have
all seen horror movies yeah you know
what I mean then horror movies go into
that type of [ __ ] you don't have to like
explain it to people I'm I'm one of
those people that it's like and maybe
this is I don't know maybe this is like
naive but I always assume I assume that
people are not idiots until they prove
otherwise you know what I mean like what
I'm talking to the person I don't like
try to like condescendingly like explain
concepts to them I just assumed that
they know what that is and then they
were having guys who they just put them
in a suit and then they stick them in
like a classroom and blur out the
background so you're really quite sure
what it was and they just tell you some
real basic [ __ ] but they get it to you
and so in some kind of format like it's
real important information they should
have stay away from all that kind of all
that stuff and just focused on what
happened around with the movie and the
making of the movie that part was
interesting I think the other half of
the damn time was just filler it did
kind of seem like that which is a shame
because it's a fascinating topic and
it's like it just it just feels to me
that they're not and maybe the other
episodes will be different but it does
seem like the first two you know the
Exorcist omen only about maybe 10 15
minutes of it we're actually talking
about the movie and talking about like
all the [ __ ] that happened on the set
yeah that was like creepy and everything
and then the rest of it was just kind of
like asking random people yeah about you
know what do you think about Satanism
and do you think people can really be
possessed and they're asking people that
you know walking around downtown Boston
yes can people be possessed no injury is
this I thought it was kind of thought
episode one and I think I liked episode
one better yeah
but looking at it now this is gonna be
very formulaic and this is gonna be
pretty much a redo of everything that
they were doing in the nineties yeah
yeah that's like I said that kind of
sucks because I really like the idea for
this show I'm still gonna watch them all
I'm not saying that yeah cuz I still
want to see like what other [ __ ] [ __ ]
they blow up free oh yeah we already got
shutters so I've already paid for it for
a year so you know it kind of reminds me
of like remember like sightings the
serious sightings and the other ones you
know a little like an old school
paranormal yeah series which were they
were written they were real and real
thin in information and just a lot of
padding and filler kind of like ancient
aliens was yeah nothing but just had a
padding and filler right there yeah and
making like all these like [ __ ] going
off on one yeah and then it shoots
yourself in the dick at the end of this
at the end of the at the end of each
episode to let you know but you know
this is just what people think you know
or this is yeah or they'll say [ __ ] like
could it be the body bottom line like
yeah we know and and know everything
ends with no that's the answers always
no yeah well that's what I for a while
like you know even a haunting some of
the episodes were like that you could
tell that the people's story that they
submitted was not that scary or not or
didn't have like that many like
incidents so you could tell that they
were like really stretch and it's like
wow this person is walking down this
dark hallway for a really low it's I
need 26 minutes of material you know
because some of those stories I'm sure
like as the as the seasons went on there
like scraping the bottom of the barrel
people are like submitting stuff it's
like oh one time I heard footsteps in my
house that's like all that happened yeah
I don't think haunting even exists
anymore
I don't think Sena I mean I haven't
heard anything I've never released any
kind of DVDs they get they they were
they made it available for streaming
yeah that was it yeah but I wasn't
well they don't I I think a lot of that
kind of stuff
they don't like even bother like
producing physical medium at media
anymore because it's not worth it
yeah it's not worth it not enough people
would buy it yeah is everybody good gets
[ __ ] screw streaming nowadays but it's
um I don't know like I remember I bought
you a bunch of the yeas and yeah I
wanted the rest of them on but they they
don't they don't sell them on disk
anymore they're just it just seems like
the first you know four or five seasons
were they're pretty good at best we
kinda started to kind of get rules
either the stories got like really lame
or they got like really outlandish it
was getting really outlandish and very
heavily padded yeah where there wasn't
much story there lots of special effects
yeah yeah that's what we might have
mentioned this before there's one thing
it always bothered me about that show is
that they you know they have like the
talking head interviews with like the
people that saw the [ __ ] and then like
the reenactment well since I show well
yeah and it's like I'm like hey the
person didn't say that like did they
just say it in a part that got edited
out and then you're yeah like just put
it or are you just like trying to make
it look way scarier than it actually was
they tried to make it look way scarier
than what the person described it as
yeah because sometimes like okay for
example they'll show the shot and the
people is like yeah I just really felt
like there was somebody in the room or
something don't just say something like
really simple like that which you know I
don't have any reason to doubt that they
felt that but then in the reenactment
they show like somebody washing dishes
or whatever and there's like a creepy
like black figure like one yeah all they
said was that they thought they they
felt a presence like behind that they
didn't say they saw enough and they
didn't say anything that first four
seasons was good well yeah because those
were like kind of the big the better
enough big stories you know what I mean
like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] Matt Bobby
Mackey's yeah yeah and then like some
summer went even though summer wind I
think was a whole hour wasn't it or was
it two parts I think it was a whole two
whole hours I think summer wind is
basically two stories in one well yeah
because it was loose excessive yeah it
was the one family was there and then
her dad and brother but the more I
looked into
when the the Lester I thought there was
to it the more I looked into it yeah and
then when I saw the house that they were
talking about like oh well of course
nobody wanted to work on that house yes
I love [ __ ] I know I couldn't believe it
like what I saw the actual house because
like in the show yeah you know the house
looked kind of run-down but like still
livable like you could still live in it
like it just needed a little bit of yep
the real house looked like a [ __ ] ruin
yeah it looked like ruins like it didn't
look like you could live in there like
it looked like you would have to just
complete like tear it down and start
over yeah it looked like just a bunch of
damn boards yeah it looked like was made
of wood yeah and it wasn't that old but
it was early nineteen hundred's but it
looked like like something from the
Victorian era that was getting ready to
fall over and then remains inside it was
just a bunch of like cheap look and
[ __ ] carpeting and particle board and
I mean it wasn't a nice house no it
really wasn't so it was big though it
would somebody say that it was
somebody's vacation home and I think was
the twenties when they built it and I
think it might have been built on the
cheap back in the twenties yeah like it
wasn't and when it was kind of neglected
and then they said well it was so evil
it got struck by lightning and burnt
down but when you look when you look at
what's like on Google Earth when you
look what's next to that house was a
bunch of nice houses in there and
evidently teenagers were going in there
a lot yeah so I think what really
happened is is that the people that the
neighbors said I can't [ __ ] have that
piece of [ __ ] next yeah bring it down
approximately bring it down a profit and
the kids are coming in here nothing they
set it on fire
I set it on fire just look over there
yeah set on fire in like in the middle
of a rainstorm yeah and really it I
don't think any the the the property was
basically abandoned the only thing of
any value on the property was the land
itself burning that house down didn't
didn't I mean technically illegal but
it's not like he destroyed anything I
mean that house at the time that it
burned down was a piece of [ __ ] yeah it
looked like how like and yeah and those
are the pictures that we saw when
considered to be in good condition yeah
I saw said my other photos that were
after they had lived there yeah and have
been abandoned for 10-15 years it didn't
have any glass in it yeah that was like
nothing it just like it was just like a
shell there's like a shell yeah pretty
much with a bunch of rotten furniture
and stuff and a bunch of spray paint
because the kids are going in there and
spray painted it look like a [ __ ] the
Bandon house get ready to fall down yeah
look like a health hazard it looked like
some it looked worse than some of the
[ __ ] that like [ __ ] Dan Belling
oh yeah urban explorer look through to
you there was no arson investigation
yeah they just might yeah [ __ ] that man
nobody was living in it I've been lived
in decades as I saw yeah
what are we gonna watch tonight I guess
we don't really have to watch anything
in particular for like reviews or
anything like that because we already
got all that done with some I'll have to
like oh well there's that Korean movie
you wanted to see the one I had to rent
right the devil yeah I saw the die what
is like I've seen it already but I
wanted you to see it cuz I thought you
probably dig it maybe we'll see that or
we'll see something else depends on but
you probably have to like I said it was
on it was on shudder already but I don't
think it's on there anymore we'll see
but yeah we'll have to you know when I
mean it's Saturday night well yeah
figure out something to you probably
drinks tomorrow that we drank a lot last
night while we were recording the show
although I edited the show today and I
thought it came out really good it's
pretty funny
is it like it ended up being 2 hours and
45 minutes mmm which is not bad for just
like one case yeah usually it's you know
for show ends up being that long it's
usually like four cases like all in one
I think the next one we're gonna do is
like three or four different cases
because there were like a bunch that
were recommended I have so many like
[ __ ] I have a huge list of topics
because people are always like
suggesting them and I'm glad people do
because sometimes you know was something
I hadn't really heard of or didn't
really look into and then I feel like
it'll make an interesting show but I
have so many I have like 5 years worth
of [ __ ] topics yeah so and so that's
why I started like some of the you know
true crime shows like if they happened
in the same country or something like
that I'll kind of put them together on
one show just so
it kind of clear him out of the list but
yeah so that'll be going up on Tuesday
the one we recorded last night that I
thought was pretty entertaining and
that's probably to go yeah that's
probably about it it's Saturday we're
all right yeah we shut it down and so uh
see you guys soon be good out there
we'll talk to you again tomorrow